and I recently heard you say in an
interview that you've learned more about
the business from like rap and wrestling
than you have from anything within
comedy and I would be interested to know
what are some of the business things
you've learned from rap and wrestling
that you apply to your comedy oh thank
you for asking that I think in comedy we
a lot of us get this mindset of like oh
we're pure artists we just want to do
stand-up like so many my friends I'd
even talk to and if like why do you want
to do voice acting well you wanna do
like like stand-up is the purity and I
think if anyone sees right now
diversifying your portfolio is a
God because there's no stage for you to
hit right now but however I'm still
getting checks from trolls I learned
from from rap and from from wrestling
was self-promotion about making yourself
seem like a big deal that if you made
yourself seem like a big deal no one's
gonna believe you are a big deal until
you do and so a lot of my like I would
post about my shows I would post about
what's going on even if they were half
full I would just take pictures I would
post about them because I was like you
want to be a part of this people the
half full room that was here
they loved it you should be here they're
the cool people and then a lot of it was
like selling t-shirts and sellin posters
like when I started doing that a lot of
it was kind of looked down upon that it
was corny that it was hacky that was
that's what role comics do but I knew
every time I went to a wrestling show
every time I went to a rap show I wanted
to leave with that artist this t-shirt
because I wanted to support them because
I wanted to I thought it was cool if I
came back with a currency shirt or Devin
the Dude shirt or whatever like
and I thought it was weird that comics
didn't seem look at it like that and so
I wanted I got in the merge more I got
into self-promotion more and I got into
making like little commercials for my
for my runs from my tour like I
said they're doing that a couple years
ago and a lot of my comedian peers were
making fun of me like hey why are you
doing that it's you know you're wasting
your time if they're stupid they're
low-budget they look weird but I like I
love low-budget commercials it is a
little it's a local commercial for like
hey I'm coming to your town and I
you not like a year later clubs were
requiring that I send them a video and
then my and then I started seeing oh my
parents are making commercials now wait
and I was like oh you were you are the
one making fun of me was like you know
when it comes to business I don't like
to be a follower I like to be a leader I
like to think about what we could do
different what we can do better that's
one thing I'm doing right now I'm
partnering with this company pro
wrestling tees calm and they've been a
big help in the pro wrestling community
with helping independent contractors
independent wrestlers sell their own
merch online they provide the t-shirts
they provide like the shipping they
provide everything you just provide the
art you set the price point and it's
been such a godsend for the wrestling
community I was like why don't we have
this for comedians we probably sell more
shirts than wrestlers and so now we're
starting at we got a small group of
people me Adam ray Brad Williams Billy
Wayne Davis Jackie fabulous best-selling
and when we're starting like a comedy
wrestling tease with with the pro
wrestling tease guy so because I think
it can work for comedians of all levels
because they don't when I started
selling merch like they they would make
you buy a bow colder or t-shirts I
remember I was selling with some small
company and I sold like 300 shirts and
they sent me a bill and I was like
what's going on you know so luckily I
stuck because of my love of pro
wrestling I was able to talk to this
other company that was like hey that's
ridiculous like
you'll never you come hang out with us
you'll never get a bill for a cell in a
shirt wait you might you know when we
get five $10 if you sell one shirt that
month but you'll never get a bill and so
I've been working with them and building
that relationship ever since what I love
is that you weren't taking into like the
negativity of like well why are you
doing that
that's dumb that's hack I mean I've
definitely heard what were you selling
merch what what are you a traveling
salesman or something you know and we
all heard that but you were mindful
enough to be like well no this is my
journey this is my career that I'm in
control of my success and I'm going to
do this regardless of whatever chatter
I'm hearing yeah because it's me is no
different than high school you know it's
like none of us know what we're doing
we're all trying to figure it out we all
want that so what in what do we do we
just all sit around and make fun of each
other
you know so like to me I started looking
at that as a positive like if I was
doing something and I could tell that my
peers were kind of mocking it I was like
oh I'm on that something hey hot brother
and sister if you love comedy as much as
we do here at hot breath click the
subscribe button to join the hot breath
averse and then watch more videos to get
even more comedy tips